tu dois prendre un risque ouais non tu as
raison tu dois c'est comme quand j'ai
décidé de retourner à Cleveland je n'étais pas
tout à fait sûr qu'il allait
m'accueillir mec mais ils l'ont fait ils m'ont accueilli
à bras ouverts et un ouvert  cœur
encore une fois j'ai l'impression que cela s'applique plus à
vous Je n'ai vécu qu'à Cleveland mais
encore une fois j'apprécie la pensée que
Cleveland Ohio vient de rentrer chez lui dans un
Temple de la renommée du rock'n'roll
Je m'ai fait descendre la boîte au Pro
Football Hall  of Fame tu sais que Superman a
été créé à Cleveland tu sais je sais que
Superman a été créé à Cleveland tu
m'as dit qu'un certain nombre de fois tu as déjà
vu Kyle au coucher du soleil non sais-tu que
Cleveland est génial pour toute la famille
oui oui oui je te fais  dis-moi que tout
le temps tu m'envoies un texto au hasard que
j'étais un peu bizarre c'est
assez bizarre Texan gratuit pourquoi essaies-tu de
toujours me vendre à Cleveland ne serais-tu pas
rare de nettoyer Oh mon Dieu je viendrai quand
j'aurai le temps  Je n'ai juste pas le temps en
ce moment, je viendrai à  la fois où je
viens d'être très occupé tu me rends visite à
Miami tout le temps c'est Miami je veux dire
quelle est la différence entre Miami et
Cleveland c'est pareil tu as
raison c'est exactement pareil